welcome to episode or 145 of film
courage my name is Karen warden my name
is David Brandon the case you're
wondering those sweet sounds are coming
from the guitar of our guy Kevin Gant
and you know we couldn't be more
grateful to have mr. kevin gant in the
studio with us for our christmas show
and he's taking this all linux breathing
it is kevin gant is a world qatar poet
and star of Jay Duplass s documentary of
course name's Kevin Jay Duplass raised
over sixteen thousand dollars this year
for his kickstarter campaign for Kevin
on the campaign page Jay Duplass rights
who is kevin gant in austin texas in the
early 90s kevin was my hero he was the
purest most inspired artists I'd ever
seen his fusion of all american folk
poetry with a wild flamingo guitar style
was completely original and i went to
every show of his that I could but in
1995 Kevin disappeared completely from
the music scene and I had no idea why
two years ago I finally tracked him down
and we began a friendship I learned
about his about the painful events back
in 1995 that shattered his lifelong
dream of making and sharing music I
learned he had barely touched his guitar
ever since and forgotten how to play
almost all of his songs but then thanks
to a magical twist of fate I could have
never imagined Kevin and I found
ourselves traveling halfway around the
globe and back and along the way I
watched as Kevin's dream reignited right
before my eyes Kevin my documentary
debut is that story it's time to
introduce world guitar poet kevin gant
hello Merry Christmas well so that might
don't want to hear we want to hear the
voice voice yeah hello everyone in Los
Angeles and on the internet and
everywhere they
listening we have four ways for you to
get your christmas love out to us today
facebook and twitter at film courage you
can also connect with today's guests on
twitter at Gant men the hashtag for
today's show is hashtag film courage you
can follow the stream on twitch at com
just use the hashtag film courage number
three way is email film courage @
gmail.com and number four on skype the
skype line is completely open today for
those you know if we're fortunate we
have some people listening out there
listening today on Christmas Day our
skype is open la talk radio too maybe
you can give us a quick call and just
say Merry Christmas well yesterday
afternoon Kevin you were stuck in San
Antonio Texas that's amazing to remember
that it's like that I was all was over
and i had read been blessed and received
help to get from Austin San Antonio so
my trip was on the way I was doing the
ground but the I attendant unbeknownst
to me had been shut down past el paso
because of a storm amount of blizzard
and so you know I'll let you speak but
the other I'd had it was over I I was in
a Greyhound bus station all night trying
to click my heels together and I new
world cuz I because I have gotten this
far and I know that I'm actually still
going cuz I've already been told that I
am in my fantasy brain and then it was
over and i went to starbucks real close
to let you guys know that i had to
cancel yeah and i saw that tweet & and
luckily is sometimes I'm not on Twitter
and and we saw it and and then we put
out a call to action and I'm glad you
were proactive and you you put that out
there but we we got you here and and it
was an hour by hour thing and work yeah
yeah glad I had words a super grateful
because we saw sort of our Christmas
wish our Christmas present our dream
sort of you know it looking like it
wasn't going to happen so we're just
super grateful to have you here with us
today that will and that's it's actually
a mind-blowing to me
you know the generosity and spontaneous
love that people express you know
without warning you know I watched the
tweets because it was over and I was
like devastated like I had let you all
down because we've been corresponding
off and on and all of a sudden you get
this and then but instead of it being
like well it's too bad I started seeing
tweets come up hey Kevin get to LA well
what could we do do you think is it
possible that is there somebody driving
from there or is it then that was Kevin
what's your date of birth and I was like
whoa wait a minute what is someone do
you know so most of you can probably
figure out what that could possibly mean
the name maybe they can tell you what
when somebody asks for your date of
birth and it's involving travel it
sounds it's starting to sound pretty
good now now let lists we're going to
talk about your beginnings but you know
we kind of want to set things up here we
got it we got to go into this territory
so we first want to hear about you
putting the guitar down went when was
that and how many years until you were
able to pick up the guitar again um I
got back from Los Angeles in 95 and if
you were to talk to be consciously
especially in Austin Texas there's tons
of us there's this generations of
musicians and I was still playing but I
wasn't it literally wasn't until Jay
contacted me that many years later 2007
so I guess we're talking 12 years when
he contacted me and I didn't know who he
was he had never introduced himself to
me back then but he's wondering where I
was because it can't find anything on
the internet and then it turns out like
man I haven't been playing I'm trying to
something was missing something
intrinsic in our artistic expression I
guess is we can't take it for granted
it's not quite like we're just talking
about you know can pass the clean please
it's not the same comes from another
place and that place was gone for me for
those all those years so I was unable to
really do anything well how did that
feel I'm let's let's this is let's take
it into how was that time for you like
emotionally when you have this talent
inside of you and it's not being
utilized
who's very it was confusing because I
used to take that for granted you know
your gala military years like when I was
about 26 and I started playing and got
to the point where I was comfortable and
southern audience and I just thought
that was like talking I was writing
these songs that i was around on other
people that did so we just write songs
whenever we want to and I didn't realize
that that movies for some people it is
depending on what type of music you do
but in my particular case with that real
spiritual and greatness it I could field
although those aren't maybe I can get a
title like I got a title that I've been
working with since the beginning of that
I called birth cry and that I know
that's the that's an album or it to the
title or two song I know that but
nothing else not one you know syllable
since then and I don't I never earned I
don't understand where that comes from
that this is what I've been working
through all these years it was confused
and then I amazingly I got over it as
well I was started working for UPS and
actually got over it so either became no
longer an artist I was someone that
worked with ups and I ran to compensate
I started running on the track every day
to compensate for whatever might yeah so
I didn't know in this until Jay started
asking me questions I had no idea that's
why all of that stuff's in the
documentary I had no idea that's what
was going on Jay was like a therapist
because he was curious and he found out
and I did at the same time it was
amazing amazing process what Jay did
with this documentary what it did for me
as an artist was he very intuitive with
you did he kind of just know things
about you sometimes that maybe you
didn't even know it was he able to draw
different things out well he was asking
questions so it had to be based on
intuition on side some level because he
was genuinely like for example the
reason why we went to Spain I'm so glad
you asked this question cuz je had just
had a new baby and his wife Jen actually
Jin had the baby whew that was close I'm
glad because you know she deserves
that's really good Mimi's her name she's
a wonderful but they were very he was
very busy I think they were shooting sod
getting ready to shoot Cyrus and had
just had a new baby so he didn't have
time to let us get into the Kevin
nuanced deeply
and just dedicate he came and shot some
raw footage asking me questions months
later he told me he had a little bit of
time and he's rewinding and listening to
me one of the questions he asked me to
cut off from eco flamenco what's that
because I don't know it's not flamingo
but do you study and then the oh my god
Jose Feliciano when I was chica on the
man don't be discouraged my whole thing
went on that was on the TV and I wanted
to play guitar like that and so that's
where it name was like wow and then so
that led to us going to Spain so this is
all intuition this whole project was
about about that actually it was a
hundred percent intuition because he
didn't have time to put it together and
produce it he had to just go with what
his gut was telling him so so I hope
that wasn't long winded but you reminded
me it was actually all intuition is this
piece of this because it of art I love a
project of love and love project a work
of art and it was genuinely love and I'm
amazed at that someone that had never
introduced himself to me remembered my
music for 17 years after the fact and
Kevin you know during these 12 years
where were you know essentially the
music died I mean did you think that you
would ever play the guitar again you
know what was it that far gone from you
well I never stopped that part of my
brain that lives on I never stopped cuz
once again Austin is a huge music town
so I would see people at the store hey
man what's going on no yeah man I'm
working on a new album I guarantee of
those people listening they'll call any
Kevin is working i'm still working on it
it's the same album except i have these
songs I've had a breakthrough literally
now I in my mind I'm just like this
somebody that's like needs some mental
patient what i'm working 2 album that
that's my current reality cuz i guess in
the universe there's no time so it
wasn't 12 years i'm looking a new album
that's what i'm doing and then j inserts
into this and it's like so what's going
on and you haven't played like oh i
haven't i've really oh yeah come to
think of it how long has it been that
long then look why not then come to
think of it why haven't so he opened all
of that um put a mirror in front of it
in had me look at it interesting yeah
well as part of that album that you've
been working on now you have two new
songs right that you wanted to unveil
here would you like to play
one of them now I'll play a song called
beautiful vibrations and the name is
derived from to Kickstarter contributors
and they both donated a thousand dollars
and I needed to give a nickname to them
and beautiful vibrations was one because
it's that's something similar that lyric
is embedded in one of my older albums
and the other one is a wild blues singer
which also is somehow embedded in a
lyric and I absolutely had to write this
song for them because that was the on
that level that's what they got they got
a free song that was written based on
their inspiration and then the other
goodies everything else so I had in
dreams by katy we gotta get those songs
out and I'm like well no I can't I tried
and it just there's no way I had to
write those songs so the the necessity
of it is what made these songs go all
right i mean do you know their names is
it ok to save their names or do they
know they are they know who they are
there they know they are okay who they
are okay just in case
beautiful vibrations nation the nation
echo proclamation all over brave new
world once were limitations no more such
frustration organic oxygen to breathe
everything else we need and more our
greatest inspiration way beyond
imagination if you can see what
his life worth living
working revelations rapid transformation
Organic oxygen to leave
thing else we need and more beautiful
vibrations nation the nation beko
proclamation all over great new
once were limitations no more set
frustration and organic oxygen to do
everything else we need
more our greatest inspiration way beyond
imagination if you can see what you
believe then this is life worth living
for warping revelations rapid
transformation
getting oxygen to everything else we
need and more warping revelations rapid
transformation organic oxygen to ruined
everybody else we need
working revelation
rapid transformation or get oxygen to
breathe everything else we need and more
organic oxygen
organic oxygen to
he
oxygen
getting oxygen
oxygen to breathe every
oxygen
wow that is absolutely beautiful thank
you thank you I'm so happy to have the
song beautiful this is film courage
we're live on la talk radio com in film
crews calm every Sunday we are in studio
with world guitar poet and star of Jay
do pluses Kevin mr. kevin gant we got a
little taste of that polo chill out
there they're very using me thank you so
much up there you know just love
listening to you play the guitar thank
you yeah I really just felt sort of in
the moment and and I forgot we were even
doing a radio show I'm glad that's only
that's only the second live performance
we've had here Kevin yeah really yeah
only the second live performance in
studio Sandman Wow yeah i'll have to
look the sandman up by the way now he's
the red cowboy enjoy his documentaries
way oh my elizabeth lawrence excellent
do you remember the first time that you
picked up the guitar and began playing
it and how did you discover this gift
that you have um i had a friend when I
was I would say well I had hendrix
posters on the wall and everything and
when I when we moved to Texas I was nine
years old and nineteen seventy when I
grew up in now and I looked back he had
just died but all I know is I was lift
lifting channels and maybe the receivers
on the news and they were showing all
this footage and he was burning his
guitar was all black and white footage
and they were you being interviewed and
at nine I didn't know he was something
he was like a political figure to me he
was this guy and he was black and he was
cool or something and he had a guitar so
that was all I Nino Soviet you know so
any way too fast forwarded by the time I
was like 13 or 14 in front of mine Gary
stegen grew up with the piano and the
guitar in the trunk that he was in band
in school and his mom was at piano
teacher and so he was required to do
these lessons every day guitar lessons
pan so we would be playing and then Gary
come in you know it's time but all I've
got to do my trumpet lesson and so
sometimes I would be in the house with
them and one of his guitar they
our guy I think his name was CJ was like
a god to us because he was probably 22
and we were like that man can play the
guitar and so I learned stairway to
heaven although I've forgotten it since
because very literally would teach me
what he was trying to teach him so that
was the beginning for me what kind of
feedback though were you getting I mean
people must have been just encouraging
you along the way to back when I was no
absolutely not I was I was somebody that
couldn't play the guitar but I was like
I wish I could be like Gary cuz he can
really play but I would kind of heap
taught me a scale or something and I
would like sabul just do those all the
time I didn't know anything else so I
would just do those scales all the time
and that was it they would never dawned
on me until I was in the military and I
was in my 20s I was like you know what I
really want to be able to really play
the guitar why do I have to pretend and
too bad all ever I had a complex or
something that meant that I too bad I
can't do I never never dawned on me that
well you can really you have five
fingers on each hand if you want it to
so it was a real a real slow drip
process to actually being you know where
I am today so and when you got into the
guitar man how many hours would you play
the guitar for okay I came to I can't
even quantify that because it was just a
birthday to man it was all day night and
not only then I was doing this because I
was like my god get my fingers have to
be like did it it's a compliment two
three four five so what you're doing
there's just holding on your head and
just counting on you just touching your
thumb with each finger and pretending
that I was like I'm like lanata the Al
Jarreau of guitar really looked a little
images in it he said he's amazing gene
but of course I could never be able to
really do that but making pretend you
know so even when you didn't have a
guitar in your hands you're still
playing the guitar what you're saying
and to kind of qualify that a little bit
there's hundreds of guitarists all over
the place thousands and you guys you
gals you relate to what I'm talking
about I don't want it to come off like
wow look how he did it he's touching to
me I think we all do that you know you
know all the Abuna guitar players are a
lot
in order to be like satriani for example
something like that's going on you know
so anyway I'm kind of rambling a little
bit but yeah absolutely absolutely
absolutely what was the decision for you
or or or how did you come upon the
decision to come to LA for your music oh
wow it's hard it's not hard to answer it
but there's so much for me that but the
bottom line is I wrote a song called The
Ballad of OJ Simpson and it's on cdbaby
now on my album the capacitor and the
reason why I wrote it is because when
the worldwide phenomena that was the
horrible tragedy in the subsequent trial
and the ratings and all of that in
Austin Texas people were like honking
their horns and asking me where I hid
the knife because I looked like oj it
was a comedy thing and I was like what
and it's a long story short that
happened and all of a sudden this light
bulb went off and I was like I'm gonna
write the ballot of OJ Simpson this is
such Adam this event is there's nothing
in us unprecedented in history where all
the feeds in the entire world or locked
down for six months for a trial all
programming including talk shows will
not be broadcast because we have to
compete with the other networks we can't
not show nothing like that has ever
happened in like TV history but to go on
going for that months and then it's you
know again and again so I was like there
has to be a song I'm the one that shall
be the default poet so that's why I came
out here I had an amazing opportunity to
come out here they specifically on that
and so I was just kind of skipped to do
and come in here not realizing what la
is you know it's very good but it also
is very you have to have your whole
thing together out here and up to that
point I mean how how long had you been
performing in Austin like how did you
feel about your music up to that point
making this decision to then come to LA
I thought that I was ready for the next
step if there's such a thing I had went
from being someone shy who couldn't even
play it an open mic in front of you to
hosting open mics and showcasing opening
for Jeff Buckley South by Southwest
showcases so Austin is a type of place
to where you can
it generally speaking when you get to
that level in your mind that's pretty
much it it's not designed to Mike okay
now here's your publishing deal there's
nothing like that generally going on
people can get plucked out of that but
that's the routine there and so somehow
in my mind it was like now I must go to
New York or LA and you actually you know
sign a record deal well then your life
in la at that times hit a brick wall and
and as you say and and your music and
your dream went away can you talk about
that time a little bit I'm sure it's
well no no actually I mean physically
there was an incident that happened with
one of my cousins it's in the
documentary and basically I got my ass
beat and that was on you know when it
happened it was like nobody wants that
to happen but I had I literally was put
on the greyhound bus in 95 and there's
so much the story and I you know got
back to Austin when I got back there
were some friends is that they know
about this because I had like some lumps
on me a little bit in there like to him
do you all right and so then you know
everything kind of went down and I
started working for a call center you
know so other than I guess I repressed
it so I was just living my life and
continuing to supposedly get ready to
play the guitar and start working
another album but that there's the live
impasse that's where is like that's
where it stayed until Jay emailed me was
right there at that point I didn't
realize it you know what kept you alive
during that time was it stifling it and
sort of just going into the routine of
life and not feeling anything I'm
because a lot of people would have given
up and checked out with drugs or alcohol
or depression or something else but so
were you able to just kind of stifle it
and just go okay well here's my job and
I need to be here at nine o'clock and
and now that was pretty much it and
number you mentioned they did a
substance abuse number one it was what
you know I you've gotten to that routine
of the working and number two the quick
response is my mom based on the
experiences that we had growing up my
mom totally put the fear of substance
abuse in me and to the point
to where substance abuse is absolutely
not an option for me not because I'm so
strong that I God just never you know
drink but it's just that's just not the
profile that's been embedded in me
that's not going to happen so I think I
can thank her I can assure you no thank
her for that I mean looking back on it
looking back out of Kevin I mean do you
wish that you had gone to maybe Seattle
or New York you know do you wish you
know that you had not come down lay or
or even possibly stay in austin do you
think that would have been a better path
for you well I'll put it to you like
this every time I come to LA it
metaphorically or physically what it
just wipes me out because I'm a little
puppy or whatever on some level and you
can't be a puppy here or if you're gonna
be a puppy you need to live where the
puppies live in LA is there a place for
the puppies could Malibu is that it no I
well it's gentler energy there but no I
hear you believe me I ok know what
you're talking about yeah and but I
wouldn't trade it well to put it bluntly
there would be no documentary without
that experience at jay's just asking me
questions and I'm glad you brought this
up because he's asking me these
questions and I'm like I have no idea
now that it's gonna I'm not Prince I
mean I don't have the purple rain cool
thing going and so I don't know what
what I wrote is what am I gonna do Ned
you just ask you some questions so in
the middle of all those questions he I
said something about L lanes oh you were
in LA when were you in Los Angeles I was
in 1995 so what were you doing he had no
idea about it and then he was off when
did you come back and then it was like
BAM oh I need to try to explain to you
my cousin and I got into an altercation
and all of his friends were there and
they became angry as well and he's like
what you know so then you know this is
he went home saying i think i have a
documentary here that's when it kind of
took that's when Kevin the documentary
kind of took off so i didn't had no idea
i wasn't waiting to tell him like what
can't wait to tell in this amazing story
i had repressed it when you talked about
you can't be a puppy in LA and I get
what you're saying believe me I struggle
with it to hear how do you handle that
when you're
environment maybe it's a festival or
being in LA where because you're so open
to energy that's around you and maybe
it's not the best energy how do you keep
yourself positive so that you don't
succumb to the negativity because
sometimes it's really easy to just get
in that mindset if you're around that
environment and I remember you talked
about what you're on in line for a plane
and you notice that everybody's energy
was weird and you're like oh that's
right they're going to LA yeah I was I
was coming back from the tacoma of the
film festival in Tacoma and everything I
had been to I was in I think New
Hampshire before that if I'm getting my
timeline right and then I was in Canada
for 10 days which is another story and
then I was in Tacoma so everything was
that be just normal that all of a sudden
I was at the terminal the gate to go to
LA and something was going on and I
didn't even consciously not like what is
he looking at me in there and then and
then I was like oh these people are all
going to Los Angeles and then I had to
put on that whatever i don't know if
that's real for everybody but for me
it's it's something that I still haven't
completely move in that direction
because I think it's also very important
because we have to be who we are
everywhere this is planet Earth and
we're available to be part of it too so
we can't just because somebody has a
sneeze when you enter the room you can't
let that just destroy your artistic
endeavors so it's I think it's good for
me it's good for all of us it's a
galvanizing now at some point you're big
can go over the edge and you have to
know when that is but so what is it that
you do to sort of protect yourself from
that especially if you have to play and
you want to remain true to your music
and who you are how do you how do you
keep that out or do not you just not i
don't i don't know if it's if it's um i
think it would be more important from my
perspective to deal with it you know la
I understand now being here why did the
slogan I handling handle your business
and handle your business it's not like
oh that's a cool saying think I'll
remember that when and passed it along
its no because you have to handle your
business out here you really do you have
to handle your business everywhere but
if you don't then you can kind of
mediocre around and then you'll be okay
and not realizing that you didn't handle
your business but here if you don't
handle your business you're going to
know real quick if there's something
that you're in the
midst of doing in an environment with a
lot of people are doing the same thing
if you're not handling your business and
there's no guarantee you if you handle
your business that it's going to happen
the way you intended so it's good for me
to understand what that means for me
personally as an artist and what is it
that I need to do whether I stay here
whether i go back to austin or whether i
commute back and forth or you know all
points in between okay but most people
do not get a second chance the universe
found a way you know to put the guitar
back in your hands you know what can you
say about that you know what you know
you know here you are back in the
position and it's great open in the show
and you're playing the guitar and you're
and you're performing your you're back
in front of people on stage first thing
that pops into my mind is when I first
did open mikes at Chicago House ice to
cancel them because it you'd have to get
a slot and then I was all I'm not ready
and so slowly but surely I did the thing
to wear dammit I'm a grown man I will do
this open mic I was scared to death so I
did the first open mic and not too long
after that Jay Duplass saw me performing
so the Genesis for this happened right
there and in and I didn't know it cuz he
didn't come up to me and shake my hand
he was a felt he was a student at UT he
wasn't even grad hadn't graduated yet
and his brother was visiting from New
York if I remember the story right and
they opened the door and heard me do
have the song so that's when it happened
right there maybe that's what faith
means on some level because you don't
know what's already being lined up for
you and it can take awhile it can
receive as though that that isn't that
phenomenal that's what really is going
on here at any given point I could have
I could have consciously told the
universe and I'm almost concerned to
even say that just in a or an example
because there's no such things as
examples in the universe but I could
have stopped back then and i actually
did stop but before i stop i had planted
those seeds and i'd never contradicted
those seeds verbally so those seeds
still grew just like something grows on
the ground and it comes up and turns
into a redwood that's exactly what
happened it's fascinating to me that it
can it's a it's a clear example of what
go what we have the potential to do in
our lives
I mean water still is no because it at
the same time you could have not
performed you know and so those seeds
that grew and took 17 years to really
you know be that full-blown tree are you
know whatever you want to call it you
know like yeah it could have gone you
know it could have never manifest no no
I no one would have ever known no one
would have ever known and it came down
to one individual mm-hmm that's it we
are in studio with kevin gant i heard on
d Tim nor speak help i'm saying her name
right to or okay good i hope so and she
was talking about dig and and I don't
have you seen that documentary but she
was saying that the music industry is
almost like the Mafia that some of the
record companies
how has the music game changed the 90s
are mid 90s you were in the game and now
well I have a worldwide distribution
deal right now now if I said that back
in what 90 whenever it was that would be
like wow congratulations and it still is
congratulations because we have the
freedom but somebody from Japan bought
my CD first and I get six dollars out of
that that's a worldwide distribution
deal so it's up now it's like okay do
people want to buy your product or do
they are they inspired by you so it all
comes down now to the relationship with
a worldwide audience and where's there's
still a learning curve for us to realize
that I don't know whether this is always
wrong but I think a lot of people still
think that something is going to happen
and then they need to somebody to
discover them and then they get a deal
it's like know you have a worldwide
distribution deal right now and if you
don't you can go to cdbaby.com and have
a worldwide distribution deal in 30
minutes and just kind of click on the
agreement and upload your songs and you
can cancel the agreement whenever you
want to that's how it's change it's
amazing right so it's much easier now
with YouTube and everything to just be
you can do whatever you want now now the
question is do you really have something
that's you know that you have a fan base
for order you know you know often time
you just mentioned this a moment ago you
know oftentimes it just takes one person
to believe in you to believe in your
talent and having that right person
champion your work can just make all the
difference in any person's life how much
has Jay Duplass and his kickstarter
campaign meant to you it's just changed
my life it really is I walked into pond
in one respect if I see if I it wasn't
my Kickstarter campaign with Jays
Kickstarter campaign for the documentary
and it helped for like festivals in what
end you know
if I had my name is Kevin and I'm trying
to raise money I would not have probably
wouldn't have reached that goal or come
close to it and so he said instrumental
in that number one and number two I
haven't been able to thank him yet
because he won't allow it he literally
is saying Kevin thank you so much for
agreeing to because but he wanted to do
if a piece of art that was his and he
didn't have to you know it was like it
wasn't a corporate order or the picture
business thing that which means you know
I don't completely understand that but
those of you out heard they're involved
in that know what it means the artistic
you know struggles to try to do things
the way you want when it's being funded
by you know large entities and he's like
not this this is my documentary and so
he was very thankful and to this day he
tells me all the time he's thankful
literally and started dawning on me like
wow he's not just being polite he's
really thankful so you know ditch
trumping my thanks to him he really did
if that's what's amazing to me as well I
mean as you say that it's like we're
hearing the other side of the story
because you know kara and i have we had
the privilege to talk to jay we did sort
of a video skype with him around the
time that the kickstarter campaign was
going and we kind of talked him a little
bit of a campaign and we got to hear him
speak about you so that this is great
you know you know flipping it around and
hear your side of the story so that was
just kind of running through my mind as
I'm listening to you talking about Jay
this is it's really turn a ting to me
that that's where his heart genuinely is
about me when he heard me do half a song
in 1993 and that it never went away for
him that's fascinating i did i'm so
thankful I've made it if there's such a
thing this is it you'll be I'm on the
show now film courage because of that
and no matter what happens tomorrow this
is it for me I'm so thankful for that
you know let's talk about life since May
you know since the Kickstarter campaign
how many places have you been able to
travel to and you know because this is
this whole thing has been sort of what
Jay was envisioning was sort of a
comeback tour for you you know to put
you in a position where people could see
this film and where you could get up on
stage and performing
and and share your music with folks he
tell us a little bit about um should we
premiered her South by Southwest and
then everything the floodgates just
opened and I was I guess carbon copied
on all the stuff jaye Jaye's assistant
Jeff man and Josh Pollan were
instrumental in organizing the calendar
and keeping me up data so basically by
the time it got down to me they were
letting me know him flight arrangements
are getting ready to be made and these
vessels will be contacting you directly
by email so I know I did I'm thinking 30
festivals well from March through and
that did Napa Valley was my last
festival that that was for the year I
can't even describe when when I got to
the hotel in Napa Valley and I looked at
the room i emailed them Jay Duplass Jeff
man and Josh Poland and you you guys
remember that old calgon commercial yeah
take me away I found cuz you know how
everything's on youtube I was like I was
like I hope that's cuz that's the flash
I got I was like guys you would not
believe the hotel is in its like
personally my finances are none just so
you guys know the Kickstarter and Jay
was very you know manage those funds
that Kickstarter money has nothing to do
with like Kevin's candy money or six
flags money or going to sea world that
has nothing to do with that is
specifically for and what may happen
next year there's five festivals so far
next year and so personally my finances
were done but I'm getting shuffled all
over the country in these places this
the place was I said I sent them the
link i said something like blah blah
blah Calgon take me away and then when
you go to go to youtube you look at it
as like as the woman cow God because
that's where I was living there's a
fireplace there in the bed was all it's
just it was a nice day I stayed there
five days so that goes that story goes
on and on with diff all the different
locations a lot of those hotels there
are the arrangements that I stayed in
with just this phenomenal if you get
discouraged or you feel like giving up
what's the conversation in your head
that stopped you I processed it at the
time and it may not be a specific mantra
but I know better than
you know unless it's time for me to
leave this plane and then that's not a
bad thing either in you know in you know
based on you know what we're all
eventually going to you know move on so
that what's that's the worst and people
have been matter of fact people have
been through much worse than whatever my
little artistic my life revolves around
this dream for better or worse and it's
a guitar and it's singing those people
don't even have the opportunity to be
free to do anything and they never for
generations so the fact that I'm even
speaking about it it's it's a blessing
so those kind of you know circling
around and my brain brings me out of
that you know that pretty much is the
answer for that sometimes it may take
all night because I've had some like
slim patches here like in the last
couple months but if it takes all night
it did and I come out of it being
refreshed in you know affirmed once
again you know Kevin I just wanted to
see if we you know because when you meet
for those listening when you meet Kevin
again in person you know that there's
this just this presence that you have
you know not not everyone that you meet
is as present and in the moment as you
are and so I would just love to hear you
speak on on being present and you know
and also I love to hear you know you
have this ability you know because like
we said at the top of the show you were
you were kind of stranded in San Antonio
and yet here you are it's to do today
you have like this thing where you're
gonna sort of rely on the universe and
you're going to rely on the goodness of
people and we just love to hear you talk
about that a little bit i'm so thankful
it's over and over again and I think
years ago I'm trying to get this in real
time because you deserve the answer but
I'm remembering things as you asked the
question i can remember at one point
towards like the early 95
trying to remember the one named Lou he
was in a band he was in the gourds was
kevin russell louise a doctor maybe i'll
remember his name in a minute cuz he
wasn't a doctor then he's an amazing
guitar player now he's a doctor but at
that time i used to host open mics and
one time they saw me by UT and i was
walking around and they gave me a coat
and so man i need to remember his name
but this is one of many examples at one
point maybe maybe that next spring i was
talking to somebody about this we were
sitting in chicago house peg peg been in
Glinda's club and everything that I had
literally because I tried to find
something to break that sir everything
that I had my shoes my socks my pants my
belt my shirt the guitar everything that
I had was something that someone had
given me mmm in that community and it
just so you know is it naturally occurs
now translating that into what would
happen and when you're trying to do
something LOL a while it's a whole
nother animal but you're making me
realize it that's exactly what I'm doing
I'm not aware of it it's just that in
the moment there's going to be so like a
flowchart there's some decisions and you
like sometimes you know that's a hard
one but now this is the this is the
decision because if this doesn't happen
at least I'll but that's where i'm at
think we all do that but for some reason
I'm doing it this is my aura that's it
that's not taking into account or 10
years from now you can have an IRA you
know I don't go that far and that's not
always a good thing I wouldn't suggest
it but that's just the only way I know
how to do it and thanks for recognizing
that because i am doing that i could
have easily my heart was hurt my heart
was I can't say broken because of what
we talked about before you know there's
a lot of things going on in the world so
I can't say my heart was broken because
I can't do the radio interview it hurt
really bad though that I had to email
you guys and cancel the day before
because I was in Texas and there was a
snowstorm a night in had been shut down
there was no way it was going to happen
but for some reason my foundation has
been laid through all of these
experiences and that's where faith is
you have faith based on your past
experiences we could talk for two more
hours of
amazing things that happen that
shouldn't have happened based on me just
standing there you do all you can do and
then you just stand and I just stand
it's like well just stand that's all you
can do so instead of laying down and
curling up in a ball stand and if the
fireball and ghost you you were there
standing when it did and so so far
fireball has an income for me and you
met a young man to while you were there
who just had a very tragic thing
happened Oh in the bus at the bus
station and you were able to say you
know what and you were able to your
right to feel for him and say thank you
yeah there's I don't know if anybody
here is in Texas now listening to this
but I have no I don't know any of these
people at all but I had a rough night at
the Greyhound station when I knew that
we were frozen and I wasn't going
anywhere not because of San Antonio but
because of Del Rio you know I can't get
couldn't get past a real so gory hon
what moving so i was sleeping on the
floor all night and then this moping
around but trying to keep us trailer
normal effect and i overheard a
conversation and to the gist of it where
there was a man at the greyhound that
was waiting for his friend to come in
and i heard him tell somebody yeah my
friend I've known him since we were kids
he just lost his entire family they were
coming to pick him up at UT for the
holidays he lost his mom his dad his
brother and his sister nett it just
happened so his friend said was just
come and stay with us for the holidays
and so that completely put the film
courage interview just somewhere else
folded it up and put it back my wallet
how can I complain you know there's
nothing I could do but just like I went
and talked to him about man you're doing
a wonderful thing for your friend god
bless you and I just you know hope the
desk but I don't even know how you would
process that it young man is a UT
student in these 22 years old by the way
if any of you all know this if you know
him because you go to UT support him you
know don't be afraid to come up to him
because it was such a tragedy just hug
him or whatever it takes because that's
a big whammy it's about as bad as it
gets so anyway that these different
things come in your life that allow you
to process things in real time and keep
your perspective honest
yeah not such a tragedy you know are
these our hearts go out absolutely
that's just got to be just mm-hmm so
pain doesn't it change your perspective
it does yeah and it puts in perspective
trivial things that one might have cess
over yeah and that's what I was doing
and it did Jane had changed my
perspective so I went to UM starbucks
because there was no Wi-Fi at the
Greyhound that there was one a couple
blocks away and I went ahead well based
on that okay I'm just gonna cancel
that's all I cancelled with you guys
well we we have just a few minutes left
and you do a see honor of another song
wildblue singer soul forever lingers
hovering mysterious so as not to be
ignored wild blues singer soul forever
Elena's hovering stickers so it's not to
be ignored you can ignore me if you want
i'm not gonna ignore you because you but
to me I know what you're going through I
know everything I was already here in
the beginning wailing on your behalf
making you cry sometimes living
in between why don't you try to do
please be sure always
so I don't have to intervene wyalusing i
er sorry forever linger as a hovering
mysterious take it ignore me if you want
to i'm not gonna ignore me I know what
you're going through I know everything I
was already here in the beginning wobbly
singer you solve forever lingers yeah
hovering mysteriously
so it's not to be ignored wobbling area
saw wherever leaguers pop in mysterious
ways
Wow
forever winners
mysteriously
he ignored
hovering mysteriously that's beautiful
that is absolutely beautiful thank you
thank you that one love that thank you
so much we've been speaking with world
guitar poet and star of Jay Duplass as
doc Kevin by his music on cdbaby com and
search kevin gant connect with Kevin on
twitter at Gant man and go to the
Kickstarter page for their successful
crowdfunding campaign and thanks so much
Kevin thank you Karen if you happy
holidays everyone yeah yeah we couldn't
think of a better Christmas present so
we're just super thrilled happy here as
our Holly get holiday gift for everybody
you know and we're a little bit over we
got to get our guy Jim Norris yes in gym
get him get him ready in studio so shout
out to you Jim merry Christmas to you in
Christmas these companies on nicely
dressed yeah he always has a suit on
he's coming next with sapphire planet so
we wanted we want to be able to
transition to him and I guess we should
just thank each of you for joining us
and making us a part of your 2011 and
we're just super grateful so we're just
wishing wishing you that the happiest of
holidays yeah and um yeah thank you all
for all your support yeah it's been
great and until 2012 yeah til 2012 and
we look forward to being here with the
next Sunday first thumb at noon la talk
radio we're going to be joined by
filmmaker Jake stettler he's a longtime
film kurz listener he won our movie
poster puzzle contest Jake is in
post-production on his feature no
sanctuary and we can't wait to UM kick
off next week with you Jake next year
with you Jake yeah and have a safe new
years everyone